[Music]
two
then a little bit of what would be the
God that is not seen do not put it in the
middle of the windshield let's say when you
they say look old forward you believe for not
let's say I'm stoking that about
we are one you are whatever and they are
I usually answer yes yes where you
feel more comfortable
[Music]
disappear gubern or do not work anymore
that stop operating here we are moments
of famine and above comes this monster
this to trample does not know who
are you fighting
he does not know who he has are why
they are ghosts are invisible
[Music]
without first thinking about a government
rooted to the popular movement come
a multinational of prepo to get into
this taking on all kinds of
regulation all kinds of conquest of the
workers
nothing happens
nothing happens the workers are of
laugh no
to
I see it as a possibility of
magnificent work and it is the technology that
nowadays there are for the
Uruguayans through the security of the
community in what is coming is what
there is
I say is the world we live in today and
I think barbarous is my way of
earn a living my way of keeping my
family my way of having my income
[Music]